[Musique]
le matin alors que les cafés font encore
leurs toilettes il est un homme qui lui
a déjà commencé son travail depuis
longtemps pour lui pas de vacances ou
bien rarement car tous les matins il
doit assurer sa tournée de livraison
sans tenir compte des jours fériés qui
pour lui n'existe pas c'est le livreur
de classe
[Musique]
monsieur s'il vous plaît
il voit monsieur vous ne pouvez jamais
prendre de vacances vous savez chez nous
c'est assez difficile
on travaille tous les ter jeu
et autant vous n'avez pas pris de
vacances à sa précision est-ce que
l'intention d'en prendre l'année
prochaine peut-être quand vers le mois
de décembre où est-ce que vous irez à ce
moment là j'ai de la famille à dos vêtu
rang et je me venant par dessus merci
vous cloue messieurs
et
certes lorsque l'été fait reynisson
paris une chaleur étouffante tout le
monde pense à la glace ce qu on oublie
trop souvent c'est que le besoin s'en
fait sentir tout autant lorsque la
température est moins élevé était
éclatant était pluvieux trop frais pour
les amateurs de chaleur de toute manière
retenu par ses clients habituels le
livreur lui ne peut abandonner son poste
ne peut quitter paris pendant toute la
durée du mois de
[Musique]
ce qui est vrai aussi pour certains
marchands qui ont en cette saison toute
une clientèle à satisfaire
nous sommes dans le quartier de notre
dame dans un magasin qui fait commerce
de ces objets de toute nature auquel on
donne le joli nom de souvenirs souvenirs
objets qui rappellent un fait objet
donné par une personne pour qu'on se
souvienne des telles sont les définition
donnée par le dictionnaire de ce mot
utilisé dans ce sens mais peut-être
convient-il d'un employé un autre celui
de preuves car le voyageur vient souvent
chercher là la preuve des voyages qu'il
a fait c'est sans doute pourquoi
certains de ses souvenirs se présente
ici sous une forme d'objets usuels il ne
faut pas trop s'étonner de voir des
cathédrales gothiques devenir plateau ce
qui importe c'est que le voyageur une
fois de retour chez lui puisse montrer à
ses amis se souvenir qu'il a voulu
conserver de ses voyages
pour les propriétaires de ce magasin en
cette saison point de vacances possibles
c'est ce qui nous explique fort bien eux
mêmes
monsieur les stages est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de rester ouvert tout l'été
oui certainement obligatoirement
d'ailleurs notre métier veut que nous
soyons ouverts à plus forte raison l'été
en raison même de l'afflux des touristes
qui est de plus en plus important au fur
et à mesure que nous avançons mais
justement c'est ce que je vais vous
demander que représentent les mois d'été
dans un commerce comme les autres où ils
représentent les mois d'été représentent
la moitié à peu près de l'activité
totale de l'année
minimum dans cette raison portage est
très important c'est indispensable mais
est-ce que vous avez motion qu'il y ait
un changement de quelques années il ya
certainement un accroissement régulier
du nombre des touristes qui viennent
chez nous et c'est tellement vrai que
cet hiver même mois de février nous en
vidéo qu'on ne voyons pas habituellement
notamment les australiens
ces australiens sont venus parce que
paraît-il ils ont les moyens de
touristes des moyens de tourisme très
rapide l'aviation l'avion naturellement
et du tourisme à crédit également qui
leur permet de venir
à cette époque-là de l'année qu'ils
étaient chez eux alors auparava nt pas
leur continent est-ce que vous
travaillez beaucoup ici énormément
depuis huit heures du matin jusqu'à huit
heures du soir ça vous intéresse et ont
donc vous avez terriblement besoin de
vacances à quelle époque qu'est ce que
vous voulez prendre au mois de février
ce qui nous enchante pas parce que je
préfère la place
et là vous êtes obligés d'aller aux
sports d'hiver je ne fais pas de sport
c'est produire
en quelle langue sont les livres que
vous désolé madame en anglais je
m'occupe presque essentiellement des
touristes américains et anglais je les
guide le mieux possible dans leurs
achats et parfois je les conseille sur
les différents livres aussi bien sur le
louvre que sur notre dame les aquarelles
et diapositives alors expliquant les
monuments de paris et je m'occupe du
change aussi sont assez déroutés par le
nouveau franc
quelquefois je les consoles il ya une
dame très âgée qui est venu essoufflé
après avoir fait le tour de notre dame
deux fois impossible de trouver le
tombeau de napoléon
dans le magasin nous pouvons apercevoir
quelques uns de ceux qui justement
prennent des vacances se taire à ferrer
avec lequel il s'empresse autour des
comptoirs pourrait nous le faire oublier
[Musique]
oh
ce sont bien pourtant leurs congés leurs
loisirs qu'ils occupent ainsi et la
pluie elles mêmes de les dérange guère
et c'est peut-être justement une des
qualités de l'être humain que d'occuper
ses loisirs à toutes sortes de tâches
qu'ils jugeraient rebutante si elle lui
était imposé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hahaha
[Musique]
autre métier de vacances c'est à dire
métier que font certains tandis que
d'autres sont en vacances celui de
moniteurs
tout autour de paris il existe
différents camps aéré ce sont des lieux
où l'on accueille les enfants qui n'ont
plus trop s'éloigner de la ville pendant
l'été
chaque jour on les conduit dans une
piscine on leur apprend à nager d'abord
à terre suivant une nouvelle méthode
puis dans l'eau évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous leurs jeux sont également
surveillés n'ont lieu que sous la
direction de leurs moniteurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous les retrouvons dans le centre de
l'union d'optique française de créteil
institution technique qui dépend du haut
commissariat à la jeunesse et aux sports
et qui est gérée par différents
mouvements de jeunesse là les enfants
peuvent s'adonner aux sports nautiques
en toute sécurité en effet ici aussi les
moniteurs veille sur eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès leur arrivée on leur enseigne les
premiers rudiments de la navigation
[Musique]
ne lâchez pas
encore
[Musique]
numéro 1
re deux
volets ou bien quand le plat bord bons
numéros 2 3 en avant
je n'oublie pas de maître capello
bordélique qui arrive
à gauche à gauche
animé au 4
et 5 tu peux partir aussi
contre le pl borne haute
un
beau 5 et 6
on ne peut pas donner la mort
cette note
marc cherry froide mais tu appelles au
brevet
ml à l'eau
oh
malgré tant de précautions prises il se
produit parfois quelques incidents parmi
ces navigateurs d'occasion incidents
sans aucune gravité puisque les
moniteurs sont toujours prêts à
intervenir
[Musique]
c'était exactement le travail des
moniteurs monsieur jacquet chef du
centre de l'union nautique française va
venir expliqué
monsieur jacquet depuis quand
recevez-vous les enfants du centre aéré
au club nautique nous le recevons depuis
début juillet qu à la fermeture des
activités scolaires jusqu'à quand les
nous les recevons jusqu'au 3 septembre
après il ya le temps de ranger le
matériel c'est la clôture donc début
septembre et quelles sont les activités
qu'ils ont dans votre club veut nous les
initions au canoë d'abord avec les
grands canaux et a10 ensuite les canoës
biplaces on leur fait aussi une petite
initiation à la voile et vous recevez
combien d'enfants environ chaque jour de
60 et pour ses enfants vous avez combien
de militaires moniteur nautique j'en ai
cinq oui et les enfants viennent jusqu'à
quelle heure chez vous les enfants
arrivent le matin vers 10h a mené par
les autobus de la ratp et s'en vont en
fin d'après midi chaque jour ils
rentrent chez eux et lorna le travail
est fini pour les moniteurs ah non pour
les moniteurs le travail n'est pas
terminé pour autant il ya d entretien
des bateaux la flottille ça il faut la
surveiller incessamment tous les jours
est ce que les enfants viennent tous les
jours de la semaine ils viennent en
semaine mais le dimanche les activités
des centres aérés sont arrêtés nous
avons notre activité disons normal de
l'union nautique c'est à dire recevoir
les jeunes gens et jeunes filles en
week-end qui viennent ici pour signifier
aussi à la voile et au canoë c'est
l'activité principale du centre en
dehors de l'accueil de ces centres aérés
n'était pas si jacques est de quelle
façon recrutez-vous moniteur nous lui
recrutons dans nos séjours de vacances
parmi tous les jeunes qui fréquentent
nos centres y en a qui prennent goût
ensuite à devenir moniteur nous lui
recrutons ce qui bordaient propagande
par exemple auprès des mouvements de
jeunesse des grandes écoles ce à peu
près nos moyens de recrutement de
moniteurs est-ce qu'ils passent un
examen oui font d'abord un stage à
pâques un stage d'initiation on en fait
swan si en savoie ou à bénodet en
bretagne pour les former sur les plantes
que nous est dévoilée pédagogique et est
ce que c'est une profession pour eux ou
simplement un métier complémentaire
qu'ils font d'urle recours quelques uns
d'entre ces d'un métier permanent qui
font comme moi même toute l'année mais
pour une bonne partie d'entre eux c'est
un métier complémentaire d'été ils
viennent l'été encadré dans nos centres
les activités des séjours de vacances
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils font le reste de
l'année mais en général ils sont
étudiants où il travaille
mais par exemple le jeune homme qui est
derrière vous
bah je suis étudiant en technique qui
grincent moi je suis étudiant à la
faculté de sciences à grenoble ouah je
suis en 4e année d'école normale a
choisi moi je suis ajusteur ou dix
heures à paris mais moi je préfère
quant à moi je suis moniteur permanent
donc chaque jour en fin d'après midi les
enfants arrange les pagaies qu'ils
retrouveront demain déjà l'autobus qui
assure le transport les attend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où vivez vous habituellement mes sujets
au centre même je vis au centre même
s'il habite là douze mois par an
oui toute la main et vous n'aurez jamais
prendre de vacances aussi l'envers et où
allez-vous est noire et bien au ski
les en attendant l'hiver et les pentes
neigeuses le chef du centre et ses
moniteurs continueront à assurer leur
travail ce travail de l'été
[Musique]